thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you're here
Natalia is with us in Nashville hey
Natalia how are you I'm Morley
Natalija okay sorry about that I said it
wrong how can I help you pay day long
and I'm not able to pay them back right
now and they keep calling me and telling
me they're gonna drive my paycheck and
I'm unsure what to do okay how much how
much do you make about twenty two
thousand a year okay and how much in
payday loans do you have out about five
thousand good lord
okay and how much do you owe on your car
I'm not always paid for it was a gift
from my dad that's awesome what's it
worth about four thousand I believe very
cool you're single yes okay and you're
working forty hours yes okay and what
other debt do you have other than the
five thousand payday loans I'm gonna win
school so I have to mount it but I don't
I'm not paying it just [ __ ] because I'm
still in school
yeah and how much do you owe on that
about twenty nine thousand okay any
other debt of any kind no okay all right
well first we need to be real clear to
understand payday loan people are
legalized loan sharks you know that
right I do now well you're paying like
eight hundred percent interest yeah so
they're getting you're just just getting
your face slammed they're just they're
just beating the snot out of you and so
the first thing you have to do when you
wake up in a situation like this is you
have to say I am never going in one of
those places again for any reason no
matter what happens ever you agree with
that yeah never set foot in one of them
if you're hungry go see your pastor
don't go in there again you cannot
ever do this again agreed I agree okay
good that's the first step
the second step is they are going to
come after you because they are in the
business of ripping off broke people and
they are guess what broke people
oftentimes don't pay them so they have a
real system for coming for your throat
as you have already noticed right yeah
okay so it's going to get nasty
sooner than rather than later so what we
need to do is we need to come up with
five thousand bucks as fast as we
possibly can
there's only two places to do that one
is out of your existing income by
cutting your expenses down to nothing I
mean nothing how much is your rent my
dad that's awesome you have no rent
mm-hmm so where does your paycheck go
you don't have a car payment Oh shopping
mmm not good with money
okay where else does it go that gas to
get to work right yes you have insurance
on your car I do how old are you I'm 21
okay and you're paying the gas and the
insurance cuz you got a free car right
yes and you don't have any costs to live
there no okay all right so would you
agree with me that your plan I listen
pronounce your name one more time for me
it's Natalia Natalia so I have done a
lot of stupid things in my life and when
it when they cost me money and I get my
self into a mess like you're in I've
tried to figure out because it sucks I
mean it's no fun where you alright knows
no fun agreed right and so you got to
learn something from this and take a
lesson from it and say okay things are
going to be different or I'm gonna be
right back here again if you keep living
like you've been living right yeah so
are you ready to change everything about
the way you handle money I'll help you
I'll help you if you're ready are you
ready I am okay
all right so what is your take home pay
about 17,000 a year no about how much
when do you get paid once a month twice
a month two weeks what
twice a month of life that a month in
the 15th okay and how much is your
take-home pay each check uh it's about
eight I believe about eight hundred
dollars a check did you get a big tax
refund um I have not received Texas yet
because of I didn't recess so I have to
get my identity verified and I've been
doing it the process of doing that now
okay but have you filed your tax return
I have and what is your refund going to
be uh 36:82 okay you need to change your
withholding at work because $3,600 is
$300 a month coming out of your check
too much mm-hmm so we need to bring home
$300 a month so have you got a pencil
handy okay write down step 1 go to
payroll and change your withholding to
bring home 300 a month more hmm all
right we need to get more money coming
home because right now you're just
sending too much to the government and
then they're sending it back to you in
April does that make sense yeah okay now
you got to get this I step to get the
identity theft thing verify get your
identity verified and get that refund
and give that to these blood sucking
leeches that you gave money to called
payday lenders thirty-six hundred of
your five thousand is gone you got it
right but you got to do that fast
because they're coming after you the
second thing is you have $800 a month
I mean $800 twice a month right now when
you change it you're going to have a
little bit more than that but eight or
nine hundred dollars and all you have to
buy is gas and insurance so you should
be able to give these payday people five
hundred bucks a month five hundred bucks
a check mm-hmm all right five hundred
bucks a check plus your thirty six
hundred gets these people gone in three
checks a month and a half they're gone
okay and you won't get garnished but you
ain't going shopping you heard me yes I
understand you're not going into a
restaurant to eat you heard me can there
is no partying you hear me I heard
because you're you know you got your
button slinging although I get it out is
get this stuff straightened out you're
gonna have to lean into this and fix it
now do you want to break this forever
and learn how to be great at handling
money I do I will give you the class
Financial Peace University my 9 week
class to go through if you will go to
the class okay but you have to learn to
do the stuff in the class and you can't
miss a single class if I give it to you
free oh but you go in there and you
learn how to handle bunny and then
someday when you're like old like 30
years old or something you can give the
class to some scared 21 year old okay
you can pay for it when you got some
money some day pay a full pay it forward
you know what I'm saying
if you promise to go to class I'll give
it to you but so you got to get your ID
theft thing straightened out so you can
get your refund to give it to these
blood sucking leeches you never go in
those places again you immediately put
yourself on a very tight budget you give
them $500 a check which in three checks
is 1,500 plus 3600 makes $5,000 go away
mm-hmm you what you follow my mouth here
yeah but you're gonna have to lean in no
screwing around okay if you need some
help you call me back and I'll walk you
the rest the way through it but you just
if they call you just tell them jump in
the creek you're bringing money and and
just bring them money over there just
bring them wheelbarrows and money is
what we're talking about and you make
these people get out of your life by
paying them off as fast as you can and
then you never set foot in those places
again this is why I can't stand payday
lenders they feed on people like her
they feed on their blood sucking leeches
I don't know if I like you saying that
I'm a payday lender well then you ought
to get a job you could be proud of your
blood sucking leech you take an
advantage of the very people that cannot
afford to pay your interest and you're
ripping them off and you know you are
get out of that business go find
something to do with your life where
you're not destroying young woman's life
like that right there yeah she walked in
there yeah of her own free will she did
stupid we've all done stupid of our own
free will I'm glad everything I did at
21 years old is not broadcast for 10
million people to hear it
good lord can you imagine so yeah just
just in case you
thought you were cool because you all
got stuff like that in your closet don't
you don't want it coming out you don't
want people to know everything she was
brave to call in here but she got some
help too and that's what we do here I
tell you the truth but we'll walk you
out of it and you know most the time the
problem with our money
whether you're 21 or whether you're 61
you know the problem with my money the
problem with your money guy the gal in
your mirror ladies it's a lady you put
on makeup with man it's that guy you
shave with he's your problem you get
those people to behave then you'll have
plenty of money she's no different
you're no different and I'm no different
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind